[Music]  Oprah Winfrey says she knows that she  wasn't meant to be a mom everybody can  take a deep breath now lady Oh makes the  confession in the April issue of Good  Housekeeping UK telling the mag quote I  didn't want babies I wouldn't have been  a good mom for babies I don't have the  patience Oprah calls the students at her  Leadership Academy in Africa her girls  joking that she's a mother to the  world's children to be a mother and to  be a mother who stays at home and takes  care of your children or to be a mother  who stays at home and then goes outside  the home to work I mean I just don't  think there's any higher calling in life  than that so I had such respect for them  and felt like that I represented them as  their surrogate  [Music]  you